N
EUROPE.
IT EXISTS NEXT TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY CALLED RUSSIA.
RUSSIA IS A BIGGE COUNTRY,
RUSSIA IS A POWERFUL COUNTRY.
RUSSIA DECIDED TO INVADE A
SMALLER COUNTRY CALLED UKRAINE.
SO BASICALLY THAT'S WRONG.
SPEAK UP BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SEE WHAT CAN BE,
UNBURDENED BY WHAT HAS BEEN,
AND THEN TO MAKE THE POSSIBLE AY
HAPPEN.
>> TALKING ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE PASSING OF
TIME.
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE PASSAGE
OF TIME.
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
THERE IS GREAT SIGNIFICANCE TO
THE PASSAGE OF TIME.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND THE
PASSAGE OF TIME HASN'T BEEN KIND
TO HER OFFICE.
SHE LOST TEN HIGH-PROFILE
STAFFERS IN THE LAST NINE
MONTHS.
THE MOST RECENT OF WHICH WAS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR NANCY
MEDICAL DOWN A PERIOD AFTER HER
DISASTROUS AND FRANKLY
EMBARRASSING TRIP TO EASTERN
EUROPE LAST WEEK, WHO COULD
BLAME MISS MICHAEL DOWNEY?
BUT THE DYSFUNCTION
DOESN'T END THERE.
A NEW BOOK BY REPORTERS REVEALS
A GROWING TENSION BETWEEN THE
BITING AND HARRIS CAMPS.
APPARENTLY THERE BENT OUT OF
SHAPE THAT BIDEN DUMPED
IMPOSSIBLE TASKS ON HER LAP.
BUT THIS DIRECTOR REPORTEDLY HAD
A DIFFERENT TAKE.
IN THE NEW BOOK, "IN PRIVATE,
BEDINGFIELD NOTED THAT THE
PRESIDENCY WAS THE FIRST TIME IN
HARRIS' CAREER SHE HAD FALLEN
SHORT OF SKY EXPECTATIONS.
HER SENATE OFFICE HAD BEEN MESSY
AND HER PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
HAS BEEN